NARRATOR: What do
ancient Greek prostitutes
and World War II
soldiers have in common?
Red lipstick.
That's right.
Turns out the
iconic bold red lips
have a surprising history
of sex, power, and war.
Back in ancient
Egypt, lip rouge was
worn by both women and men as
a symbol of status and power.
Cleopatra herself
wore a shade of red
made from a lovely concoction
of crushed insects,
fish scales and beeswax.
Over in ancient
Greece, lip rouge
was for the less
glamorous side of society,
seen as something used
exclusively by prostitutes.
In fact, there was a law
stating that prostitutes had
to wear makeup
when out in public
as to not deceive men looking
for real relationships.
Fast-forwarding to
the Middle Ages,
lip painting continued
to court controversy,
mostly caused by criticism
from the Catholic Church.
Lipstick was
portrayed as satanic.
Women were even supposed to
speak of their lipstick use
in confession.
But when Elizabeth I took
power in England in 1558,
she fully embraced lip rouge,
almost always wearing it
in public and private,
even claiming it contained
mystical healing powers.
Sadly, the lead content
of her lip coloring
may have contributed
to her death.
Lipstick's popularity
started to fall over
the next couple of centuries,
hitting rock bottom
during the Victorian era.
Queen Victoria herself
described makeup as impolite.
But in the United States, lip
makeup took on new meaning
during the rise of the
women's suffrage movement.
Suffragettes embraced bright
red lipstick as a symbol
of feminine resistance.
They were taking decisions
into their own hands,
the color of their lips,
and the right to vote.
Red lipstick's popularity
exploded and grew even faster
after the popular swivel stick
design was introduced in 1923.
Cosmetics became one of the
largest industries in the US.
But not everyone loved lipstick.
Adolf Hitler hated it.
He banned it
because, in his eyes,
lipstick made otherwise
Aryan women impure,
and because it was
formulated from animal fat
rescued from sewage.
So the Allies took advantage
of Hitler's disgust
and made red lipstick a
symbol of feminine power
in the war effort.
Companies introduced brand new
wartime shades, like fighting
red and victory red.
Montezuma red, designed by
Elizabeth Arden in reference
to the US Marine
Corps song, became
part of the official
uniform of the US
Marine Corps' Women's Reserve.
American factories who
employed women during the war
were required to
keep lipstick stocked
in their dressing
rooms, allowing women
to retain a sense of
femininity and continuity
in uncertain times.
In England, where a variety of
consumer goods were rationed,
Winston Churchill left
lipstick untouched, recognizing
that cosmetics were
an essential part
of maintaining a feeling of
normalcy among Britain's women.
The Ministry of Supply
stated, "Cosmetics
are as essential to a woman as
a reasonable supply of tobacco
is to a man."
A little out of date,
but you get the point.
The allies won the war, and red
lipstick continued its journey
through the back half of the
20th century and into the 21st,
and continues to be
an indispensable part
of the cosmetic arsenal.